I want you to program this now.
I want you to run 1,000 simulations
using a function simulate that you have to fill in.
In this simulation, you count how often you succeed in the variable k.
You pick a random door using the function randint.
If you give it the parameter 1,3 it picks a number between 1 and 3 at random.
You make your own choice using the same function randint,
and then you have to emulate Monty.
Sometimes it picks it deterministically. Sometimes it picks it stochastically.
Write that code and then flip your choice of the remaining door.
If that remaining door is correct, implement k.
Otherwise, don't increment k.
When you run this 1,000 times, your output should be approximately 2/3.
This program requirement requires real knowledge of Python.
If you're new to all this, feel free to skip it. It is a big challenging.